if you've been holding your breath and
anticipation for a Mass Effect remaster
this story might be a bit of a downer my
name is Jake and here's why ei has no
plans to remaster the original Mass
Effect games as of now ea could make
easy money on remasters of the original
Mass Effect games but the publisher is
unlikely to make them in part because
they would distract from Mass Effect
Andromeda this is according to EA
executive Peter Moore who said in a new
interview that EA probably won't pursue
any remaster projects across its entire
catalogue because it would rather look
to the future this shouldn't come as too
much of a surprise because EA is one of
the few publishers that hasn't been
remastering games from the last
generation Moore told IGN
or a company that is focused on
delivering for the future I was asked
the question once about remasters and I
said it's just not what we do
we've got incredibly talented dev
studios around the world who are focused
on delivering new IP new experiences and
more and more live services can we make
an easy buck on remastering Mass Effect
yes have thousands of people asked me
that yes they have we just feel like we
want to go forward there's a little
thing called Mass Effect Andromeda that
were totally focused on it Bioware and
it's gonna be magnificent EA has to date
avoided entering the game remastering
business even speaking out against the
practice hopeful fans got some better
news earlier this month when EA boss
Patrick Sutherland said EA is absolutely
looking into the remaster space though
it sounds like Moore's comments suggest
otherwise maybe I'm a bit too hopeful
but I'm still holding out for a remaster
things aren't all bad though Mass Effect
Andromeda is scheduled to release next
year but if you want to take a trip down
memory lane
check out my history of Mass Effect
video on gamespot.com
or our YouTube channel and for more on
Mass Effect and Mass Effect Andromeda
stay tuned to game spot